[Music]
let's finish the job let's protect the
lower prescription drug costs for
everyone let's expand health care for
more people and to get care let's keep
building the economy from the middle out
and the bottom up
President Biden in town today touting
steps his administration is taking to
reduce health care costs for seniors it
came as the Department of Health and
Human Services and Medicare
beneficiaries will pay less out of
pocket for 27 drugs now the affected
medications have seen their prices rise
faster than the rate of inflation
President Biden took the opportunity to
call on Republicans to support his other
efforts to lower drug prices
there are different they're just
different they continue to be determined
to repeal the Affordable Care Act
and you know it's hard to believe but
they've already voted to change or get
rid of the Affordable Care Act since it
passed 50 times 5-0
the new Medicare policy is expected to
save seniors up to nearly 400 a month
the newly discounted drugs Street
medical conditions ranging from cancer
to arthritis kidney disease fungal
infections and acne